well I mean for the very very new actor
somebody said something to me once that
insulted me I was insulted by it but the
more I thought about it the more truth
there was to it and that was you know
take the cotton out of your ears and
stick it in your mouth watch learn don't
be talking about you know don't try to
make yourself out to be more than you
are or try to impress anybody just be
right-sized I don't know if that makes
any sense you don't have to be bigger
than you are you don't have to be
deferential to anybody you don't have to
be smaller than you are just be
right-sized but just be a watcher and an
observer and learn how things how things
work and it's it's like any other
business or endeavor a year that you
become involved in you have to learn how
to do it and and along with learning how
to do things technically in this
business and creatively you also have to
learn how to diplomatic diplomatically
approach situations that come up from
time to time and it's it's just it's
just all part of the game but the secret
of being able to do that is lasting long
enough to be able to do that and for me
it's been getting in line and not giving
up my place in line for anybody or
anything and because I forget what the
the statistic is but every year there's
some huge number of actors that have
been here for a year or two and then
they are not here anymore they vanish
they're called sundowners they'll stick
around for a year and they'll give it a
shot and then they'll you know they'll
just give up and the attrition rate is
very large in this business so get in
line stay in line and don't give up your
place in line because people in front of
you in the back of you are going to
particularly in front of you are going
to give up they're going to decide to
get married they're gonna go open a
restaurant there
you know for whatever reason decided to
go in another direction and give this up
so you very quietly just step forward
take their place in line and with any
luck and persistence and talent where
are you gonna wind up close to the front
of the line and you know I'm not at the
front of the line yet I kind of like it
where I am right now
but it sure beats where I used to be at
the end of the line you just have to
stick with it be persistent and and
you'll be okay even if it doesn't work
out you'll be okay everything's gonna
everything's gonna be fine sundowner
that's fascinating what have you known
any sundowners oh sure sure
there were people that I worked with
years ago that were amazing actors
amazing actors and they're not here
anymore
if I told you their names you'd say who
never never heard of them but they were
absolutely awesome but they decided to
move in another direction
is that because it was too frustrating I
don't know could have been any reason
but they're not here and I'm still here
am I the most talented actor in the
world oh my god no no I mean I have my
little niche I do what I do I still have
tons to learn
but I stuck around and they didn't and
and I'm here I'm so grateful for that
you